Who do we dream of? We dream of the
smell of powder, the smell of gunpowder, the smell of
dirt, these sounds.
[Music]
People. I
mean, in my situation, I live in the fact that the best squadron is the
one that is in
sync. The goal is for the horses to remain head to
head and the shot to be at the same time.
[Applause] Well done, may
God reward you with goodness.
People.  People said in
the past, the knight's grave is always
dead, like the thanks of the brothers, this is the crescent. This thing used to be
taken off, so I was young, I was not Canadian in even anything, and I was too old to venture out. I had not
completed my university studies in Diyali.
This time, I was busy with seasons and
festivals. I had reached 16 years old and faced
a favor, but everything was as if it was the same.
The question is,
I wanted to know how I entered the field for him, and there is no
criticism from men because
this is their religion. I mean,
it is a monopoly on them. I was singled out for marrying
women. We were like a different message. [Music] [Music] The whole world has returned to carrying the lights. They are not in their best
condition.
[Music] May
God bless
you.
[Music]  Music]
[Laughter]
appr
Come on, come on
[Laughter]
[Music]
Come on [
Music]
Non L S Bb
Sha [Music
]
God [
Music]
[Applause]
[Music] We
say hello
to you. Come to the
salon,
God willing, you will have my brother.  Let
us tell you,
[Applause]
[Music] You came
and won the gold medal in the year
2008, okay? [
Music] This
was the longest period of time that I did
not ride. Look, don't cut it with your hands, don't let it go, let's go, let's go, let's go, let's go, let's go, let's go, let's go, let's go
In your head, where are you in the
imaginary police school? God willing,
where did you grow up? Whoever wanted to be a police officer and nothing happened. Hello, hello.
[Music] Hello, come on, sit down, sit down. Everything shows. My
whole life is like a circle around horses.
I'm
grateful. Sometimes I feel like my head is
suffocating. Freedom was so brutal.  The one who
gives and complains, let me know that you are all the same. The one
who was able to say, oh, you are
not dead, what am I? [Music] And I find hope. I am in the village. Muhammad Zuwayna, may God bless you, one of the festivals. No,
no,
people are like a reminder of you. The shake that shakes and gives me a sound. Find me. I
know what day we
will gather with me and gather with you all.  One of them
was like a joke with me, he didn't hate
anything, some of them imprisoned him for their personal reasons, the
others got married
and had a son, and
finally Ihsan D
Q, and God
knew that I had to turn against new girls.
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 Oh
Mojo, may God protect him, Dah, Shan Mas, like a
horse on the stick, everything will be on
you, like that.  A role model for other girls, small families, men, who
chose them to see any, any
simple mistake, anything that I understood Adam. They went out, one fold, half a
meter, half a
meter. May God bring you the highest peace. How many people
killed
someone.
Ha, ha, your pain. This is the kohl, according to Joshi, in the middle,
but here the kohl is walking, here,
here.
[Applause]  ] Hi
Mama, I don't want to cheat on my daughter. May
God bless you. She's not a daughter. May your
education teach you to me. My daughter, or
tomorrow, something
else. And
let [music]
in [
music].  ]
The introduction, and He is the Most High, the Great,
glory and the descent of obedience, God willing, may
God make you the Lamb, the dialect of the wool, God, there is no god
but He, the Life, and the truth is that I
no longer know, I am still in [
music] the
H level with several medals,
including the Grand University Medal
[music]
[Applause] The
navigator, the veil, I missed the veil. I don't know what it is, since it is not there. I mean, in the
veil, they gathered for me. I have a wonderful light in the veil. They gathered for me. The
field is clear, its start is high. Hopes for the
foot. [Applause] May God bless
you.
[Applause] Where is the
spelling? Uncle, no mistake is enough
for us.
So many
people who encouraged me, but how many years we lost. Please
show them that I am still the leader.
Amal
[Applause] Elaine [Applause]
Come on [
Applause] [
Music]
[Applause]
[Music] I
learned that we are a fabric of many things that are
made of
gunpowder horses, but also that I am a mother.  I'm miserable, I'm the nucleus of my
family, I'm so old,
things are getting
old
[applause]
Bo
[music]
vai